[Music]
let's go to chicago illinois
where chad joins us chad how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call i
appreciate it you bet what's up
well uh tonight i'm going on a birthday
dinner with my bride and
i need to bring up um finances
again and uh you know i read the total
money makeover a few years ago and i
i understand the baby steps and
you know step one's done working on step
two but it seems
a bit one-sided and she's not fully on
board
which makes things difficult so is it
your birthday or her birthday
my birthday happy birthday hey chad
thank you yeah
i'm just gonna take a stab in the dark
here okay
okay um
guy who wants to talk finances
at his birthday dinner may be a guy
that doesn't always have the right
timing to talk about hard conversations
and maybe has a wife who is really
gifted
at tuning out and nodding because
chad's got a lot of ideas about a lot of
things in a lot of different places
am i onto something or no tell me if i'm
wrong i said the first part's right
okay i would like to second
my colleagues under no circumstances is
tonight the night
gosh to talk about how she needs to get
on board with the finance issues
this is your birthday brother enjoy your
birthday yeah you're gonna
kill the night and i don't know what
big ideas you had in mind so back us out
of here so
you got all excited tell us what
she said when you when you're like hey
babe you gotta watch the youtube shows
you gotta read the books you gotta
i'm all in let's be all in what was her
response
well she's she gets behind the idea
but then um you know didn't
doesn't really have the time to i'd say
put into that
then she's not behind the idea what is
it about the presentation of the idea
the information what is it about it all
that she won't
investigate it because if you came and
said hey i've picked us two
two vacation spots that i paid for in
full either hawaii
or london i need you to sit down and
look through these with me
she'd sit down and look through so what
about this
this life-changing journey y'all could
go on
that she says yeah it sounds great i
just don't have time right now
you know i i think it has a lot to do
with the past and
kind of the upbringing with money and
you know we don't
we don't have we have separate things
financially now you know
five six years in the marriage one i
think just
making that why do you have that
you have kids well yes we have kids now
so she runs her own business so she runs
a lot of things through
that's that's fine as well but you guys
trust each other enough to create humans
why don't you trust each other enough to
share a checking account
yeah like it seems like a sticking point
on
her side not my side and it may be if
our
you know parents did things and that's
just what she's familiar with
okay this is a marriage issue
not a money issue marriage first money
second on this deal
one thousand percent okay
my guess is there's other places where
y'all aren't on the same page am i right
no no chad
is the guy that's trying to talk finance
on his birthday dinner are there other
places where y'all
are not connected
i i'd say no like we're
so here's what i want you to do tonight
i don't even think you know the answer
to that
exactly right i want you to ask her that
i'd say no
but yeah but there is something that i
don't know let me tell you why i don't
think you know now john's the expert in
this area
john i don't think chad knows because
she's got her own money
they got it's not their money it's her
money she's running her own business you
got her own bank account you don't know
where you guys are disconnected because
you don't have any say you don't have
any insight into half
if not 80 percent ninety percent of what
she's spending money on so
i i think john is has uncovered
something here
right here's what you are talking about
here's what you are
you're a really good human being
and you have a sweetheart and i think
you're a good husband and i bet you're a
great dad
are you a good dad yes yes
i 100 agree with that and
i think you are a great roommate
and it feels like your wife and you are
living parallel lives
and can nailed it on the head
with a mallet this is not a money issue
this is not a how can you convince her
to get on the same page and do the dave
ramsey plan
this is a we're running on parallel
tracks here
we share kids and we share a home and so
i would love to see tonight's dinner be
about for my birthday hun
i want us to go repel deep off the edge
here into how long you've been married
five years you said
i'm gonna be six gonna be six
honey let's paint a picture what would
you if you could snap your fingers what
would the next six years look like
what would it look like not just talk
about it i'd like to know what would it
look like where would we be sitting
where would we be living what would our
kids be doing
what would that vision look like how
would we get there together how what
would i need
to do how could i support you how could
i live into this how could you
support it i want you all to create a
vision together that'd be a great
birthday present not when we talk about
finances finances comes when you start
reverse engineering that dream
and say well here's how we have to live
today so that thing can happen tomorrow
but you're not there yet absolutely
right
chad i mean that's the plan man and do
not
start talking about money if she starts
sharing dreams stay in dreamland
stay in dreamland don't take it to the
money it's your birthday for heaven's
sakes
gee whiz you're gonna party like it's
your birthday
yeah right yeah wow how does that go
drink bacardi like
yeah it's your birthday chad so listen
can i for anybody listening if you
on any issue are just
not connecting with your spouse trying
to
give more information say it louder say
it quiet or say it in spanish say it in
that's not the issue the issue is
there is some sort of defense mechanism
whether as chad said maybe it's it's
from their childhood
maybe it's they're tired because you're
always got a scheme maybe it is this is
dave ramsey's plan is one of 50 weight
loss plans you get rich plans
and this is just another one in a series
whatever the thing is
it's a connection issue and you've got
to get beneath that and say honey when i
bring this up
what about this scares you what about
this when i say hey i would love to get
out of debt and change our family tree
what is it about me communicating this
i'm not doing a good job of selling it
because the freedom part feels right
what about this scares you and let them
say i don't want to give up vacations
i don't want to get a second job i like
staying at home with the kids i don't
want to feel
let's have that conversation otherwise
you're just
two people two trains going on the track
and you bump into each other every once
in a while
and you just keep going and going and
going yeah i
here's what i've learned from 23 years
of marriage and i've learned it from me
blowing it
so i want to be very clear right here
this is not an expert opinion this is
the day
this is the doofus you are an expert
you're an expert expert
we make mistakes when we try to talk
about strategy instead of direction
we must as john was saying you got to
get connected so there's a connection
on direction once the connection is made
on direction then we can start to figure
out but we've got to be on the same page
about what mountain we're trying to
climb
it's worthless to talk about strategy
you can talk all you want to hey here's
how we climb around here's how we climb
around here's climbing
and if we're both thinking about
different mountains it's a problem
people make the
mistake and he wants to talk strategy
yeah she's not even on board with
direction
it's worthless to say hey we need to do
this
this this and this and go whoa why would
we do this we've all seen a football
team
whether it's a professional one or you
played on like high school or college
the coach comes in and says here's my
one goal i want to win games
but there's always a receiver who wants
to get a lot of yards
yeah and so when the coach says hey we
need to run these plays this week
oh come on i'm not gonna get any catches
i'm not gonna need touches right
you got two competing directions there
right you gotta get everybody together
yeah good stuff